Our experts in emotion interview.
Uh,
we have the honor of
speaking with Dr Marion,
the France to consider the question of
whether men and women emotionally differ.
So doctor La France is a professor of
psychology and of women in gender studies
at Yale University where she teaches
courses in social psychology and gender
psychology as well as
nonverbal communication.
So her research focuses on how emotion
and power are transmitted in these subtle
emotional communication cues.
Some of her recent work has focused in
particular on the human smile examining
questions such as why do when
men smile less than women?
Why do women smile when being sexually
harassed and to whom do babies show a coy
smile?
Um,
this work has received widespread
attention and various media outlets,
including NPR, BBC, NBC,
The New York Times among many others.
So I will now turn to an interview
with my local Yo colleague, uh,
Dr Marion La France.
One of the things I'd love to speak
with you about as we get started is what
first kind of captured your interest
in emotion in the first place?
Kind of where did it all begin for you?
Well,
I think if I can go right
back to the beginning,
one of the things that I remember
my mother saying to me and my Sibs,
which is pay attention
to how people say things,
maybe even more than what
they're actually saying.
So facial expression,
eye contact, gesture.
So she said it matters
how things are said.
And that was a really intriguing notion,
which is if it's how then it means that
it's not verbal and if it's not verbal
than it must be nonverbal.
And the what becomes,
what is it that they're really
communicating and that's emotion.
So that's I think,
the,
the core routes that's so fascinating
because many of what captures our
attention and emotion, our own
early experiences and observations.
Absolutely. I infect dedicated
my dissertation to my mom who,
and I said to my mom whose ability to
tell what was going on between people was
the wonder of my childhood.
That's wonderful.
So that sparked your interest in emotion.
And so I'd love to ask you a few questions
now that the many things you've done,
you know, since then, um, you know,
in trying to understand emotion,
gender and we'll talk about the smile as
well. Um, so some people believe that,
you know, men and women are
profoundly different. You know,
we've heard that they might
even be from different planets.
And I guess the question
I have for you is,
is this really true in terms of our
men and women really from different,
you know, emotional planets. Um,
do we see evidence to suggest
that might be the case?
I'm going to do the academic thing
and say yes and no, but mostly no,
that is, it is clear that there's
a profound belief that men, women,
girls and boys are different.
And the assumption usually is that
it is something essential that the
differences are not learned,
that the differences are not layered over,
but in fact come at
core from our genetics.
It is true that there
are some differences.
We clearly have different
organs and different bodies,
but most of what makes us male or female,
masculine or feminine comes much
later. We acquire it, we learn it,
we specialize in it will
become experts in it.
And the thing that's so
interesting actually is if
you take little kids and you
say, what is your, you've just say do a
little boy. What is your mommy look like?
You say, do a little girl.
What does your daddy look like?
They posturely and
expressively will do it.
It will be recognizably gendered.
So the very nature of how we sit,
how frequently we, or
how quickly we blink, um,
many of these things we acquire by
virtue of observation and Instruction and
learning. I mean that sounds
like from what you're saying,
it's not so much that men and women
are born different emotionally,
but at that,
at something over time they learn and
they're almost socialized in ways to maybe
show emotions differently or maybe
even talk about emotions differently.
Absolutely. And I think it's all of those
things. That is whatever emotion is,
it's multi layered. It is. Multicomponent.
So we talk about expressive cutty,
talk about subjectivity,
talk about physiological,
talk about brain kinds of things,
and at every component that we study,
gender is more or less large or small
and then more or less variable cross
situation. So to say that women
are more emotional than men.
True in the sense of either self report.
So you get women, are you emotional?
Yes. Women say they are more emotion,
but if you do online kind of coding
that is, you asked at this very second,
what are you feeling and how
intensely are you feeling it?
Then the gender differences and emotion
tend to dissipate. Oh, that's fascinating.
So what do you think that as we try to
understand gender and emotion moving
forward, what do you think are
some of the most, I don't know,
challenging puzzles we're going to face
as we try to really tease apart the ways
in which men and women are similar,
are different.
There are a lot of interesting questions.
A lot of data has been collected,
but we still don't know a lot about
under what circumstances are women more
emotional than men?
And is it more expressive than subjective?
That is,
if we measure only gender
differences in say physiology,
there's not much there that suggests
that there are profound differences.
But if you ask men and women,
if you watch men and women,
women are much more expressive with
their faces, with their voices,
with their gestures.
It is part of women to be expressive,
to be communicative to
if you will reach out.
And part of masculinity, at least
in our culture is to damp it down.
Keep it under wraps.
Be stoic. Yes, exactly.
So interesting.
So one of the things you've also looked
at that's relevant to this is, you know,
the human smile,
you know,
and that's something that
we're all really interested in.
Sort of why do we smile? You
know, who do we smile too?
What are the rules that govern
different kinds of smiles?
And you wrote a really compelling book
lipservice talking a bit more about this
and I just wonder if you could share some
of the observations that you detailed
in this book is to why do we smile and
is this something that can also help us
better understand gender differences in
emotion by just looking at something as
simple as the smile.
Smiley is fascinating for several reasons.
One is there is not a culture or a area
or historical period in which smiling
has not been found. So babies
come to birth smile. In fact,
we know from studies of babies in the
womb actually in letter stage trimester
babies are smiling now they're not smiling
cause they're having a grand old time.
Well, they might be, but
we don't know that yet.
What happens then is
layers of socialization,
layers of culture,
layers of exposure to different
contexts and different social roles.
So everybody smiles,
but then the question becomes who
smiles more under what circumstances?
We do know cross many,
many,
many studies that women
reliably smile more than men,
but those differences are very,
very much a function of what age.
For example,
you're talking about the largest sex
differences in smiling with women's
smelling more than men occurs between
the ages of about 17 and 23 huh?
After that,
the differences basically disappear so
that by middle age they're not really
profound sex differences.
There are also really substantial
within sex variations,
so some men smile more than other men.
Some women smile less than other women
and that variability is really quite
substantial.
Smiling appears to be in part a
signal of underlying positive ethic,
but smiling is a lot more than that.
Smiling in fact is the all purpose mask.
When people were feeling anything
but happy, they often will smile,
so it covers, it allows people
to regain their composure,
if you will. It holds people off
it the flex too much attention.
So smiling is,
I've sometimes referred to it as a
Swiss army knife of interpersonal
relationships. It is multiple. He useful,
it can establish connection.
It can stand is an apology.
It can suggest that one
is willing to cooperate.
It can indicate allegiances,
so people who smile at each other across
the proverbial crowded room or saying,
Gotcha. See you were in
this, we're a special. Um,
so that there are many social functions
that smiling serves besides being a
readout of underlying positive emotion.
That's so interesting.
I mean it makes smiling, you know, TV,
this complex and multifaceted thing
that happens just in a blink of an eye.
But that in ways is just,
you know,
subtly navigating our everyday
social exchanges. Absolutely.
Navigating I think is a terrific way
to characterize it because we smile at
strangers,
not a lot,
but smiling is one of the
facial expressions that
tends to be reciprocated by
strangers.
If I frowned at you and we don't know
each other and were passing each other in
the street, you're not likely to frown
back at me. But if I smell it you,
there may be a very quick recognition
and doing it likewise so that it gets us
through a lot of social situations
where words would take too much time,
too complicated, too ambiguous,
smiling, smooths things out.
Let's us go through without a lot
of tension or conflict or ambiguity.
And do you think that there are certain
kinds of smells that maybe, I don't know,
more socially effective than other styles
or it's actually great question and I
think that's where the research is going.
One of the distinctions
that researchers have made,
which I think has some terrific validity,
is the distinction between what is
called the Duchenne after a French
physiologist,
the Duchenne smile,
which is apparently the really
legitimate sign of genuine, spontaneous,
positive emotion and to facial features
are involved with the genuine smile.
That's the mouth and but
it also involves the eyes.
It's actually a muscle.
That circumference is the
eye socket which squeezes,
so it causes the eye to close
a little bit. It raises,
there's a little pouching
of the lower lid.
There's a little crinkling
of the outer eyes.
There's a little lowering of the upper
lid on the outside that is hard to do
deliberately. This, that is the mouth is
really easy. We all learn how to do that.
All someone has to do is imma cameras
and say, smile. We know what to do.
We may think it's awkward and it's
silly and it's you know, authentic.
So there are genuine smiles,
but there are many other kinds of smiles,
smiles that have often say,
if I'm trying to mask negative effect,
say I'm feeling actually really sad at
the moment and I don't want to impose
that on you. I don't want you to
know, I don't want to express it.
So my mouth may say happy,
happy, smile, smile.
But if I look at the, at the inner
brows, I see maybe some tension.
I see some other actions.
So there are smells like that smiles also
that come on the face really fast and
go off really fast.
Often you can see this and people who are
in public and they don't think they're
being observed,
but then there's somebody
to catch somebody's eye and
the smile comes on and the
people go away,
small drops off.
So the timing of his smile distinguishes
between a genuine and a non genuine
smile.
There are also smiles that are purely
to convey a sense of let's get through
this, let's just move along. But
smooth things out and that smile.
Everybody knows to be polite or social,
but it's not about emotion or at least
it's not about a readout of what's really
going on inside.
It's almost like a social regulator
is absolutely that interesting.
One of the things he said that I
thought was interesting thinking,
smiling to gender differences is that
there seems to be this critical period
where men and women do different smiling,
but then after that period,
I think he said it was
17 to 23 it disappears.
What do we think is going on?
Uh, why do we start smiling?
It's converging in our smiles.
I guess it's a terrific question.
There are those of a
evolutionary psychology band
who would say when mating is
most critical,
the sexist should be the most different
so that there's no confusion about who
you're going to engage with.
Others suggest that that's when the
social pressure is at its maximum to
indicate that one is
appropriately masculine and
feminine and there is no better
way to indicate femininity than smiling.
In fact,
it's at that age that young men who smile,
especially if they are
seeing this smiling too much,
the too much means there's something
odd about their masculinity,
so we questioned their inherent
masculinity. If there's too much smiling,
it also appears to be the case.
That's when gender roles,
in terms of occupations, in terms of
vocations, in terms of preferences,
gender roles really are really quite
paramount and there are a lot of
occupations and jobs and roles that are
really gendered still that is women tend
to be more care givers.
They tend to be more in public relations
kinds of occupations which require a
lot of smiling, so we know for example,
if you put men in those same occupations,
Lo and behold, they're
smiling. Rates go up.
If you put women in more traditional
masculine occupations, Lo and behold,
they're smiling drops off,
so it's less maybe at certain ages than
it about gender than it is about the
separation into social roles
that are related to gender. Yeah.
It sounds really like it's
all about social context.
Social context matters a lot.
Smiling is probably the most
variable facial expression.
I think when we look at expressions
associated with anger, distress,
a disgust, sadness, and the like,
I think then the expressions are often
more authentic readouts of what the
underlying effect is. Smiley is
the great question mark. In fact,
Darwin when he talked about facial
expressions was a little mystified with
smiling cause it didn't appear
to be functionally adaptive.
It didn't appear to arrive from some
bodily or some core notion of survival.
So what it is is actually
still a bit of a mystery.
So interesting.
I wanted to ask you a little bit further.
I mean a lot of your work too,
it's looked more broadly,
other kinds of nonverbal communication,
the smile being being one of them,
and just how these subtle communication,
uh,
pieces of information can actually
communicate really important information
about things like social power,
which seems really, really profound.
I mean, how is it that we
can convey things about our
gender identity, you know,
personal allegiances simply through, uh,
these nonverbal acts or in other words,
without saying a single word,
nonverbal communication is something
that humans need because it is simple.
It's efficient. It is, if
you will, off the record.
So if you say something
to me of a unkind sword,
I can say Jew. What was that
about? Why? Why did you say that?
But if you do a little
kind of scowl at me,
if you bodily turn away from me,
if you indicate by certain
other kinds of cues,
vocal tone, that you're really
disinterested, I can't say, Hey,
what was that tone of voice
thing? It's, it would sound,
maybe bordering on the paranoid
would sound kind of bizarre. Well,
I see a psychologist unless
you're a psychologist in
which we do it all the time.
Um,
so nonverbal communication
is a multilayered way of
establishing relationships,
of indicating you've mentioned power,
who's on top and who's not,
who's striving to move up, who's
worried about moving down? So smiling.
Another uh, example, there's some data,
there was some controversy on this,
but there's some data that suggests that
the lower power person person with less
standing the status in a relationship
is the one who smiles more.
And the high power person,
theoretically smiles list. Now,
what we find in our research is
it's a little bit more complicated,
but it can come down in some sense
to the following lower power.
People may smile more because they have
to. In fact, we find that lower power,
people say they smile when they
do because of the need to please.
They don't want to offend. They don't
want people to think ill of them.
Higher power people tend to smell when
they feel like smiling and don't smile
when they don't feel like it gets,
they don't have to,
they don't have to sort of
show affiliation. Exactly.
They don't have to be,
be pleasant.
They don't have because
they've got the standing,
they've got the status and other people
need to rise to them rather than they
need to somehow or other
be compliant or um,
differential or submissive. That's not
part of the high power rural often. Right.
I'm sure people in their everyday
lives can imagine situations like job
interviews where they're finding that
they may be smelling much more frequently
than they normally would.
For example. Um, you know,
to sort of please the higher power person.
But that's often some
of a double edge sword.
So interviewees are often
told, smile, make eye contact,
smile,
indicate you're engaged by smiling.
But often the smiling
then heads into too much.
So often what comes across is the sort
of greenness and you know sometimes in
those positions I'm smiling too much,
I got to stop,
but I can't because you know they're
there. I am with with my smile.
So smiling too much
happens fairly quickly.
That is to say that one can smile too
much without meaning to or wanting to and
it can then take the evaluation of the
person from competent and socially adept
into why are they greeting like that
when we're talking about these series
matters. So it can be almost too much of a
good thing. Absolutely. In fact, we find,
especially in studies of women
interviewees and men interviewees,
women smile a lot, a lot, a lot,
and they are seeing often is warm and
pleasant and altogether really nice
people.
But then too much smiling sometimes is
correlated with two little competence.
So if a person smiles too much,
they go overboard in one thing,
which suggests it may be that other
dimension of being smart and competent and
Rudy intellectually skilled,
some questions can be raised right.
So it brings their sort of social power
down even more. Exactly. Fascinating.
So I mean this has been really great to
talk about all your work on, you know,
nonverbal cues,
smiling gender and emotion.
And so when you think about all the
work you've done and sort of the puzzles
that remain, where do you see the
face of the future going in emotion?
Oh Wow.
What a question.
I think the thing that's wonderful about
emotion and emotion research is that
there are so many directions.
So we talk about,
we haven't talked today about it,
but huge differences culturally,
which raises a lot of basic questions
about his emotion. Universal.
Is it something that we
all share? Well, yes,
but if we say look at cross
cultural differences and emotion,
the rules for how much one
expresses under what circumstances,
what emotions are fostered,
what emotions are encouraged
to be damp down to go away,
issues about where in these massive
brains that we have our emotions located,
it's likely to be multiple.
He located the,
one of the questions about emotion I
think has to do with in some sense what is
it, I mean we assume, we know it's
everybody knows when emotion is,
but I think what researchers are finding
is it is a really complex phenomenon in
its own right and as we proceed into
the broader social world culture,
a nation,
his history,
we will also be proceeding in a more
micro level into the brain and there's so
many questions to ask and answer have
answered about those connections.
I mean it feels almost
like I would thought you're
saying the face of the future
has also, it got us started
in emotion in the first place.
Kind of questioning the core,
you know, I dunno. Bottom,
bottom up issue of what, what is
emotion, you know, in the first place.
It is a really interesting question.
Yeah.
And lots of work still remains to be done.
So in terms of lots of work,
I mean some of it, you know, we'll,
I'll try to do in our generation,
but a lot of it too will remain for
future scholars and students of emotion to
try. Absolutely. I think it's
one of those areas in which we've
come up with a lot of interesting data,
some really interesting findings,
but the questions are as
extensive as they ever were.
So what advice would you have for students
who are just embarking in this study
of emotion or maybe thinking
about dabbling with it?
What might you say to them?
Well, maybe eat, start with
an emotion that mystifies you,
um, makes you angry, makes you
sad, uh, gets under your skin.
Start with some behavior that
you've noticed in yourself.
Say blushing for example.
We know very little bit about blushing,
which is related to emotion.
If you come from some other part of the,
of the world of the rural, urban, west,
east, south, north, um, you,
you named the location of your origin,
you may be fascinated with,
it seems to work different here than
it does in some other kind of place.
So start with something that
is interesting, aggravating,
fascinating.
Something that says,
I need to know more about this.
Really? Hmm. That's a great,
that's a great place to end. Thank you so
much for speaking with us today, Marian.
Great.
This concludes our experts and emotion
and our view with Dr Marion La France
from Yale University.
Thank you again for speaking with us.